Afraid to go in?
Exploration always carries risk.
I say we risk it.
Take us in.
Aye, sir.
A toast.
Union service is just as much about mundane
busy work
as it is about adventure.
Where are we going?
What the hell?
Good morning, Commander.
Good morning, Lieutenant.
You're an interesting species.
You know how to fly one of these things?
We're about to find out.
I now command the full might of Krill.
Just wipe them off the face of the galaxy.
Let me shoot you.
You could feel
joy, happiness, affection, love.
I can have your heart or your soul.
Show the galaxy that humans are different!
That we value life, even when our enemies
don't!
Go!
Just hit the button
before you hit the ground.
Good luck.
If you do the right thing
in the here and now,
the future has a way of taking care of itself.
Hooray!
Enough!